humanoid roaches skull face death gods
grotesque body horrors the monsters who
appear in anime are limited only by the
imaginations of the animators and they
have some wild imaginations watch if you
dare
the 2001 anime series blood sea the
second in the blood franchise follows
sire
a school girl who secretly slays
monsters by night her world view changes
when she hears monsters discuss some
sort of broken covenant while her
visions get stranger something in her
small town is not what it seems the
elder bands also known as the old ones
see humans as a food source and their
primary drive is to kill and consume
them the elder bands take a number of
different forms in the series each with
different powers the last form that
appears is that of a bunny a
particularly sadistic variant with an
active obsession with torturing its
human prey what's worse is that it can
transform its limbs into various
horrific weapons and can divide and
regenerate making them hard to kill
while large bunny monsters shouldn't be
that terrifying at face value sadistic
multiplying bunny monsters with morphing
weapon limbs are quite frightening
the fantasy animation film spirited away
was written and directed by the
masterful hayao miyazaki it focuses on
shihiro a ten-year-old girl who moves to
a new neighborhood with her family they
discover an entrance to the kami world a
place full of spirits from shinto
folklore at which chubaba turns
shahiro's parents into pigs and she hero
has to navigate the spirit world while
trying to free her family and herself
from its grasp while the film is one of
the greatest animated features of all
time and it's surely memorable it also
contains one of the greatest and
scariest anime creatures ever put to
screen the world of spirited away is
full of everything from dragons to
witches and spirits of all shapes and
sizes the scariest monster perhaps is no
face an unsurprisingly faceless specter
who initially appears as a floating
black spirit with a white mask where its
face should be we discovered that it can
ingest individuals to gain mass
personality and physical traits wipe
that smile off your face you're still
smiling
at first it seems like a simple and
harmless entity but no face gradually
ingests the greed and vices of the
workers it absorbs this corruption
transforms it over time into a massive
hulking beast obsessed with consumption
and with chihiro our connection with the
young protagonist makes the horror hits
home especially well given that the
increasingly dangerous being cannot
leave her alone
princess mononoke takes place in japan's
muramachi period it follows an emishi
prince named ashitaka and his role in
the conflict between forest gods and the
humans are one to exploit nature and its
resources it's a classic story
reflecting the relationship between
humanity and nature with other worldly
and fantastical elements the most
frightening entity among all the magical
gods and beings is nago the boar god and
the leader of the boar clan in the
beginning of the film we see glimpses of
a creature making its way through the
forest and toward the village ashitaka
pleased with the monster before being
forced to fight it it is a spider-like
being with a worm-covered body and
glowing red eyes that transforms back
into a boar after ashitaka defeats it
this representation of nago is one of
the most horrific looking anime monsters
of all time it's also one of the most
philosophically complex and
adult-oriented of studio ghibli's
masterful creations
in terraformers 21st century humanity
attempts to begin the colonization of
mars by sending two resilient species
algae and cockroaches these two however
evolve over centuries to adapt to the
martian environment fast forward to the
26th century and the human species faces
a deadly disease known as the alien
engine virus this pathogen has a death
rate of 100
and it appears genetically and related
to any existing virus on earth to cure
the alien engine virus they'll need to
travel to mars to test the hypothesis
that the virus says strange independent
evolution makes martian origin likely
the unfortunate obstacle mars is now
controlled by the terraformers a large
humanoid species that evolve from those
original cockroaches and which harbor a
natural hatred of humanity terraformers
are strong adaptable and effectively
emotionless with a single-minded pursuit
of their goals what's most shocking is
they have gained nearly all the benefits
of humanoid evolution like intelligence
and opposable thumbs without losing any
of the cockroaches strength like extreme
resilience also despite their humanoid
heads decapitation doesn't affect them
or their ability to fly there are
terrible nemesis to the now desperate
human race and the reason they oppose
humans instinctive hatred adds to their
terrifying nature imagine that the
entire species faces extinction and the
only way forward is on a hostile alien
world not to mention it's full of beings
that are stronger than you in every way
and hate you as much as you hate
cockroaches exactly it's horrifying
death note begins when like yagami finds
a supernatural notebook called the death
note the mysterious book allows him to
write any name down while picturing the
named individual's face and the person
in question dies light gradually becomes
consumed by this power taking on the
god-like persona kira as he kills
individuals around the world in an
attempt to cleanse the world of all he
considers evil his opposition the
brilliant detective el who attempts to
thwart his efforts we discovered that
the death note was dropped by a
shinigami or a japanese death guard
named ryuk a spiky-haired lung-lipped
entity with ugly proportion limbs he
stole another shinigami's death notes
and left it in the world for a human to
find unlike other shirigami ryuk isn't
content to simply surf his function and
pass his time so he allows a human
access to these supernatural abilities
because in his own words i was bored
that's why beyond his own vast power
over life and death and his willingness
to let that power be used irresponsibly
ryog facilitated a human's acquisition
of powers he should not possess
apparently out of mia boredom frankly
that's terrifying
the claymore series takes place in a
world full of predatory shape-shifting
beings called yoma who are secretly
created from orphaned boys by the
mysterious organization the organization
creates parasites that can change their
host form after infecting their brains
and these yoma attack human beings to
feed off them claymore follows claire
who is a claymore a half-human
half-young hybrid who fights to dispatch
these monsters claymores too are sent
from the organization created from
orphaned girls it's beyond the creepy
that the same organization makes a
perpetual stream of mutated heroes and
manufactured monsters all from exploited
orphaned children the predatory yuma are
powerful with speed and strength that
exceeds that of humans along with an
ability to regenerate from damage they
often have oddly proportioned limbs skin
of various and human colours and sharp
teeth and claws flying gyoma also exists
adding an entirely different layer to
this breed of dangerous predators being
transformed into a yoma takes such a
toll on human host bodies that the
parasite has been known to move to a new
host when necessary altogether the
single-minded pursuit of human flesh
heightened power and a horrific origin
story makes ayoma thoroughly haunting
anime monsters a series bleach navigates
the world of currents and fallen soul
reapers aka shinigami or death gods and
it contains a number of interesting
entities most commonly you have the
hollows terrifying ghosts that originate
from human spirits and who seek to feed
on other souls while your typical
hollows originate from human souls a
subset of hollows are known as menos
grande and they're a different threat
entirely when a hollow reaches a point
where human souls can no longer sustain
its hunger it can turn to consuming
other hollows of course these kind of
ballistic hollows will seek each other
out and attempt to consume each other
which increases the menos grande's power
and size pretty quickly in this non-stop
series of supernatural predators the
gileans are the lowest level of the
menos grande and the least powerful
however it's the gideon's predatory slow
plotting white-faced behemoths that are
the most visually shocking as they tower
above their prey and blunder about
they're truly menacing foes that no one
wants to meet in the afterlife
attack on titan follows a human race on
the brink one day over 100 years ago
humanity became beset by titans a wave
of massive mindless humanoid monsters
that won nothing but to consume people
at the time humanity was overwhelmed by
their power but they regrouped and built
a series of towering walls to keep the
beings out for a century the relative
peace lasted until one day a colossal
titan far larger than any scene before
emerged and breached the outer wall this
allowed titans to once again prey on
humans who were forced to retreat into
the inner walls we follow aaron yeager a
boy who joins the military in search of
the eradication of titans while there is
variation among the titans they're
broadly best understood as gigantic
humanoids that want nothing but to eat
humans some of them vary like the
armored titan with its hardened skin or
the colossal titan who is of course
extremely large the bottom line is that
there's a whole army of giants who want
to eat us and are more than capable of
doing so
in sword art online players of a
sprawling virtual reality game of the
same name become trapped in its world
and are forced to beat the game the game
includes 100 floors of battle and a
menacing final boss tries to prevent
escape the game boasts a number of
creatively frightening or odd bosses but
one of the most sinister monsters in the
series is a skull reaper the boss of the
75th floor's labyrinth the skull reaper
is a huge entity that appears as a
skeletal centipede with a front pair of
scythe arms a fang's jaw and an
elongated skull head with glowing red
eyes what's worse is that most of its
bones including its ribs and legs also
function like sights so in essence it's
a massive quick moving pile of skeletal
blades it even moves like its centipede
inspiration adding a level of a natural
speed that makes it even creepier it is
easily one of the scariest creations
ever
parasite the maxim follows shinichi
izumi who lives in a quiet tokyo
neighborhood with his parents one night
the area is secretly invaded by
extraterrestrial worm-like parasites who
infest and transform the heads of their
prey into cannibalistic shape-shifting
extraterrestrials chinichi encounters
one of these worms and prevents it from
embedding itself in his head so it
attaches to and takes over his hand
instead it becomes a sentient alien
parasite that has to coexist with
shinichi amidst this harrowing alien
invasion once they take over a host and
reach maturity these extraterrestrial
parasites can appear completely human
simultaneously they can alter their
physical form size and makeup to create
other appendages or organs beyond their
vast intelligence ability to hide in
their host bodies and capacity to change
into pretty much anything the parasites
are driven only by self-preservation and
toward that end an insatiable drive to
consume their host body's species
terrifying
as disturbing as a yoma are in claymore
the series boasts an even more dangerous
set of monstrous foes in its awakened
beings claymores are powerful warriors
with skillful control over every aspect
of their body in addition to advanced
martial arts training on occasion
however claymores transform into
something else entirely massive monsters
known as either voracious eaters or as
the organization calls them awakened
beings flames become awakened beings
after losing control of the yoki inside
them they take massive yama forms that
are much more powerful than either yoma
or the claymores themselves awakened
beings look entirely unique and take the
appearance of anything from animal-like
forms to inorganic forms like the yoma
they are driven by a desire to consume
humans between their vast power myriad
complex appearances and insatiable drive
to consume people awakened beings are
easily some of the scariest monsters of
all time the scariest thing though is
that's something the serious heroes can
turn into through no fault of their own
it's a terrible transformation if ever
there was one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]